- [Spider-Man] You have a
knack for getting in trouble.
- You have a knack for saving my life.
(upbeat orchestral music)
- [Sam Raimi] For me it
was a great love story,
with a real human being at the center,
somebody I could really identify with.
Somebody who had to do homework,
someone who the girls weren't crazy about,
somebody who was bullied.
And yet he had to rise
up and become this hero
to protect the city.
And it seemed like they had
never heard that version before.
I had great graphic images,
of how Spider-Man lands,
what his pose looks like,
how he swings from a web.
The job was to bring that
vision to the big screen.
How would we do that?
How would we get actors to move in a way
that only a comic book
artist could depict?
That was really the challenge.
- [Jeff] The mandate was just
to make it as real as we could.
When Toby's hanging upside
down, in the pouring rain,
and she's all wet.
- [Sam] This was the
moment when Peter debugged
that she's his dream, of
helping the woman he loved.
It's also of finally getting
to kiss the woman he loved.
The vulnerability that he exposes to her.
I think that's why her
pulling down the mask makes
the moment special,
because his character longs
to be loved by her.
And to remove the mask
is exposing yourself
to becoming vulnerable
with someone who loves you.
- [Jeff] There was a considerable
amount of setup time.
We were actually outside on the backlot
with big rain machines but to
be able to see rain in movies
it actually has to be a lot
bigger drops than real life rain
so when you're getting
rained on in the movies,
it's a lot of water.
- [Sam] You do take after
take and they're being doused
in cold water and it can
become really chilling.
- [Jeff] But we would have to
get out there, get in position
and get the rain going,
and then we would have
to lift Toby up on the wire, upside down,
in the position you saw him in the movie,
and that would take a couple minutes,
so it's a few minutes of misery
each time we do the take.
- [Sam] And while he was
doing the scene I remember
the water was falling down
into his upside down nostrils,
so he was kind of drowning
but it was a kissing scene
so (laughs) he had to pretend, like,
it was a pleasant, sweet moment for him,
when in fact he was semi-drowning,
and then the only way he could
breathe was through his mouth
and then I had him kiss Kirsten.
They seemed to do very well with it.
It was more about trickery
of the mask itself.
We couldn't really get
that look on the mask
and have it be pliable, so
it really wouldn't pull up
and down, and we had to
pretend as though it were.
But Kirsten's doing a little
bit of sleight of hand
that helps sell the idea
that she actually pulled
the mask down.
It was a lot of technical
aspects but fortunately Kirsten
and Toby are so convincing that
they made that all invisible.
- [Jeff] I felt the pressure
that the genre was in trouble.
Hollywood was soured on the
superhero film around 1999.
I honestly in my heart
think that this movie
and how Sam did it absolutely
set the tone of how
a comic book movie should be made.
- [Sam] I love Stan Lee's
work and I was trying
to be true to it, and if
people recognize from those
Spider-Man movies that his
stories were really effective,
then I'm proud.
(dramatic music)